good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm
talking really fast because I'm trying
to be like John Green even though I'm
not John Green which it's something you
probably noticed I'm also trying not to
blink and I'm going down in pitch right
before my jump cuts also Hank I'm trying
to make the puffs level on my hair
higher but I don't have very much and
I'm afraid if I keep doing this I'll go
bald permanently yes I realized John
Green wears glasses but if I put on my
glasses I'll look exactly like Vsauce
and many of you nerdfighters right now
are saying to yourself he's not Vsauce
no I'm not Vsauce so Who am I hi I'm
Craig wheezywaiter that's my real last
name according to John's previous video
and Craig wheezywaiter which is his real
last name I'm responsible for that beard
over there on the vlogbrothers channel
but in all other regards I'm not
responsible at all that's why I make
clones do my chores I get back to work
clone so why am I here and when do I
leave many of you are asking well you're
not asking
you're not saying I you're saying you so
so why am you here and when do you leave
well substitute m4r
cuz John had a baby while Sarah had the
baby John helped they brought Alice
green into the world with that picture
is just a random baby that is not their
baby that might be a boy baby
no there there we go I can also try to
approximate the sound of the baby for
you hmm only gonna do that once the
reason I'm so good at impersonating a
baby is because of your most recent
video Hank how to be a baby properly
actually wrote down your list about how
to be a baby Hank to make sure I got it
right so here's your list if I
understand it correctly you're stuck in
the world get used to it cry sleep two
and a half hours at a time put stuff in
your mouth cry all the time again and
try to be cute that is exactly what I
did in college I failed at the last one
anyway Hank and John it is an honor to
be on your channel and once I learned I
was going to be on your channel I knew I
had to step up my game because I
normally do stuff like this here's me
with my shirt off am i proud of it I am
proud of it but I'm ashamed that I'm
proud of it so I needed some practice
interacting with nerdfighters before I
made this video therefore I made a
nerdfighter clone nerdfighter clone are
you there yes why don't you say anything
you didn't ask oh just being polite you
just never forget to be awesome do you
yeah oh hey listen I think I saw some
worldsuck in the bathroom you think you
could go decrease it with a mop thank
you
yes anyway nerdfighter Kalam didn't help
because every time I talk to him I just
kept getting jealous by how awesome he
didn't forget to be I just decided to do
a bunch of things that John Green does
like question Tuesday the day I answer
fake questions that I just made up but
assume that you are wondering but I'm
not going to answer real questions
because I'm not a vlog brother and I
probably answer inaccurately when's John
coming back I'm not sure but it's gonna
be a bunch of weeks and different people
are going to host in his place each week
why is your name wheezy waiter I name is
wheezy waiter because I have asthma and
I used to be a waiter do you hate Vsauce
because he looks so much like you know
we're friends such good friends no for
real
we're friends who the eff is Hank Hank
is a large flippered Marine Mammal found
in the Arctic Ocean and Hank may also
refer to the movement that a Hank makes
hey I'm hanging right now thank you very
much hmm I'm a dork will you do Sharpie
face oh I don't have any sharpies but I
do have crackers so I will smash one on
my forehead yeah that'll be my thing now
then I'll eat it too that was an easy
target to hit if you know what I mean oh
ho I'm balding it's sad what else does
John Green do thoughts from places okay
how about my office here goes often when
one thinks of an office feelings such as
confinement and separation come to mind
which is why I very deliberately located
my office in this open corner of my
girlfriend's in my abode notice the
windows lining the periphery one can
even discover infinity in this locale no
longer is there separation but
connection to everything what else
something literary work of Oscar Wilde
often contains critique of social issues
like false manners hypocrisy fraudulent
identities and nowhere is it more
exemplary than in this passage wizz-wizz
went to the Catherine Wheel as she spun
round and round probably should have
planned that out a little better
well he's often in an airport I'll go to
the airport no I don't feel like going
to the airport you know what else he's
also not in an airport very often I'll
do that instead Here I am ah this is one
of my favorite in that Air Force hey
I'll see you on Friday and dftba